Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It was a bright cold day in April, and the clocks were striking 13. Winston Smith, his chin nuzzled into his breast in an effort to escape the vile wind, slipped quickly through the glass doors of Victory Mansions, though not quickly enough to prevent a swirl of gritty dust from entering along with him. The hallway smelt of boiled cabbage and old rag mats. At one end of it, a coloured poster, too large for indoor display, had been tacked to the
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。那是一个晴朗寒冷的四月天，钟敲了十三下。温斯顿·史密斯为了躲避那股刺骨的寒风，把下巴缩进胸口，迅速溜进了胜利大厦的玻璃门，尽管动作不够快，还是让一股夹杂着沙砾的尘土随他一起卷了进去。门厅里弥漫着煮卷心菜和旧破布垫子的气味。门厅尽头，一张大得不适合在室内张贴的彩色海报被钉在
wall. It depicted simply an enormous face, more than a metre wide, the face of a man of about 45 with a heavy black moustache and ruggedly handsome features. Winston made for the stairs. It was no use trying the lift. Even at the best of times, it was seldom working, and at present, the electric current was cut off during daylight hours. It was part of the economy drive in preparation for hate week. The flat was seven flights up, and Winston, who was 39 and had a varicose ulcer above his right ankle, went slowly, resting several times on the way. On each landing, opposite the lift shaft, the poster with the enormous face gazed from the wall. It was one of those pictures which
墙上。海报上只画着一张巨大的脸，宽一米多，那是一个大约45岁男人的脸，留着浓密的黑胡子，五官粗犷而英俊。温斯顿朝楼梯走去。坐电梯没用。即使在最好的时候，电梯也难得正常工作，而现在，白天的电力供应被切断了。这是为“仇恨周”做准备的节约运动的一部分。公寓在七楼，39岁且右脚踝上方长着静脉曲张溃疡的温斯顿走得很慢，中途休息了好几次。在每一层楼的电梯井对面，那张巨大的脸孔都从墙上凝视着他。那是一种
are so contrived that the eyes follow you about when you move. Big brother is watching you. The caption beneath it ran. That, of course, is the opening of George Orwell's novel, 1984, published in 1949. And Dominic, I mean, it is up there, you know, the bright cold day in April, the clock striking 13 with, you know, it's a truth universally acknowledged, or it was the best of times, it was the worst of times as one of the most celebrated openings of an English novel. But I guess that what would differentiate 1984 from Pride and Prejudice or Tale of Two Cities is that it's had an incredible political resonance as well, hasn't it? It has indeed. Well, actually, Tale of Two Cities has had quite a political resonance. But
设计巧妙的画，当你移动时，眼睛会跟着你转。老大哥在看着你。海报下方的标语写道。当然，这就是乔治·奥威尔1949年出版的小说《1984》的开篇。多米尼克，我的意思是，它和“那是一个晴朗寒冷的四月天，钟敲了十三下”一样，与“这是一个普遍公认的真理”或“那是最好的时代，也是最坏的时代”并列，是英语小说中最著名的开篇之一。但我认为，《1984》与《傲慢与偏见》或《双城记》的区别在于，它还具有令人难以置信的政治共鸣，不是吗？确实如此。嗯，实际上，《双城记》也有相当大的政治共鸣。但是
I agree. I think 1984, well, with Animal Farm, they are two of the defining books of the 20th century. And I suppose you could say of our time, because even if you've never read Animal Farm or 1984, you're very familiar with the concepts, the idea of newspeak, of thought crime, of all 20th century writers, I don't think it's an exaggeration to say that he is probably the one that has made the biggest kind of imprint on our political consciousness. Yeah. And when you say our, I mean, he has a global reputation. Yes. The word Orwellian is something that would be understood in China or Russia, as well as in the West. But he's also a very, very distinctively English writer, isn't he? I remember when we had our discussion with Jason Cowley on the nature of Englishness in the 21st century, Orwell kept kind of coming up. It was almost as though we couldn't kind of
我同意。我认为《1984》和《动物农场》是20世纪两部具有决定性意义的书。我想你可以说它们属于我们这个时代，因为即使你从未读过《动物农场》或《1984》，你也对其中的概念非常熟悉，比如“新话”、“思想罪”。在所有20世纪的作家中，我认为毫不夸张地说，他可能是对我们的政治意识影响最深远的一位。是的。当你提到“我们”时，我的意思是，他享有全球声誉。是的。“奥威尔式”（Orwellian）这个词在西方，乃至在中国或俄罗斯，都是人们所理解的。但他也是一位非常、非常独特的英国作家，不是吗？我记得当我们与杰森·考利讨论21世纪英国性的本质时，奥威尔的名字总是被提起。就好像我们无法
leave his thoughts and his sentiments alone. And so do you perhaps have someone who's joining us who has written on this subject, Dominic? I do indeed. So we have joining us today a good friend of mine, Professor Robert Coles, Professor Emeritus at De Montfort University in Leicester, whose book, George Orwell, English Rebel, is a brilliant study of Orwell as a writer of Englishness and Orwell as a kind of progenitor of Englishness. But you know Rob Tom through his book on sport, don't you?
放下他的思想和情感一样。那么，多米尼克，你今天是否邀请了研究这个主题的嘉宾？我确实邀请了。今天加入我们的是我的好朋友，莱斯特德蒙福特大学的荣誉教授罗伯特·科尔斯教授，他的著作《乔治·奥威尔：英国叛逆者》是对奥威尔作为英国性作家以及某种英国性先驱的精彩研究。但汤姆，你通过他关于体育的著作认识罗伯，对吧？
I do, I loved it. Actually, I think we discussed it, didn't we, when Jonathan Wilson came on to talk about football. I think he briefly mentioned it. I got given it for Christmas by Sadie and it was one of those great, Christmas reads so very very thrilled to have you on and maybe one day you come on and talk about boxing or something which which is your account of Victorian boxing is still seared on my mind but today we're talking Orwell so
是的，我很喜欢那本书。实际上，我想我们讨论过它，对吧？当乔纳森·威尔逊来谈论足球时。我想他简要提到了它。那是萨迪送给我的圣诞礼物，它是那些伟大的圣诞读物之一，所以非常、非常高兴你能来。也许有一天你可以来谈谈拳击之类的，你对维多利亚时代拳击的描述至今仍刻在我的脑海里，但今天我们谈论的是奥威尔，所以
thanks so much for joining us and I wonder could we could we kick off just by looking at Orwell's life or he's not Orwell is he he's he's Eric Arthur Blair sure well thanks for that wonderful introduction you two it's so good it can only be downhill now and it's great to be on the program I've got the whole family listening to you at the moment the podcast is everything I hope university would be and it never was. Oh, we're going to bank that. Definitely. You should open a university between those two adjoining symmetrical studies you've got. We like to think that every episode is a special subject. It's a tutorial in a universe. Yeah. So today's subject is Orwell. He's born in India, isn't he? Yeah, he's born in Bengal in Motohari in 1903. I mean, he's born at the imperial high noon of the Raj.
非常感谢你的加入。我想我们可以从奥威尔的生活开始谈起，或者说他不是奥威尔，他是埃里克·阿瑟·布莱尔。当然，谢谢你们两位精彩的介绍，太棒了，接下来只会走下坡路了。能参加这个节目真是太好了。我的全家人现在都在听你们的节目，这个播客就是我所希望的大学该有的样子，而现实中却从未有过。哦，我们要把这句话存起来。绝对的。你应该在你们那两个相邻的对称书房之间开一所大学。我们喜欢认为每一集都是一个专门的课题。这是一场宇宙中的辅导课。是的。所以今天的主题是奥威尔。他出生在印度，对吧？是的，他1903年出生在孟加拉的莫蒂哈里。我的意思是，他出生在英属印度帝国权势的巅峰时期。
And he's born into an imperial family. His mother is French. Her family are... God, I didn't know that. Yeah. Good grief. Just hold on to your seat, Tom. You never know what you might learn the next hour. Wow. His mother, they were teak exporters out of Burma. They were called limousin. So his mother was French imperialist. His father was, as everybody knows, deputy sub-commissioner, sixth grade, opium trade, which the British ran for China.
他出生在一个帝国官僚家庭。他的母亲是法国人。她的家族是……天哪，我不知道这一点。是的。天哪。汤姆，坐稳了。你永远不知道接下来的一小时你会学到什么。哇。他的母亲，他们是缅甸的柚木出口商。他们姓利穆赞。所以他的母亲是法国帝国主义者。他的父亲，正如大家所知，是六等副助理专员，负责英国为中国经营的鸦片贸易。
And of course, on Eric's paternal side, way down the line, they were West Indian planters and slave owners. So between the teak and the opium and the sugar, he's certainly born into an imperial family. But he doesn't stay in India long, does he? Because he moves back when he's, what is he, about one or two or something? Yeah. He's moved out. There's a plague in Bengal at the time. And his mother takes him and his elder sister, Marjorie, home. And they come to Henley-on-Thames. Very nice. Thames Valley, which he came to call the golden country. He came to Henley-on-Thames in 1904,
当然，在埃里克的父系血统中，往上追溯，他们是西印度群岛的种植园主和奴隶主。所以，在柚木、鸦片和糖业之间，他确实出生在一个帝国家庭。但他并没有在印度待太久，对吧？因为他大约一两岁时就搬回去了，是吗？是的。他被带走了。当时孟加拉有瘟疫。他的母亲带着他和姐姐玛乔丽回到了家。他们来到了泰晤士河畔亨利。非常好。泰晤士河谷，他后来称之为“黄金之乡”。他于1904年来到泰晤士河畔亨利，
where he lived with his mother and sister. His father remained in India, remained in the Imperial service. But the thing about him that's really interesting is his class position. And Orwell was a brilliant writer about class because he had this wonderful formula. He said, we were part of the lower upper middle class, which our overseas listeners will find absolutely the most English thing you could possibly say. But basically, I mean, to cut a long story short, and correct me if I'm wrong, Rob, it's a family with expectations and with a certain sense of respectability and all that, but without the money really to uphold it. Is that about right? Yeah, that's about right. When he says upper middle, he means the cultural
在那里他和母亲、姐姐住在一起。他的父亲留在了印度，继续在帝国政府服务。但关于他，真正有趣的是他的阶级地位。奥威尔是一位出色的阶级作家，因为他有一个绝妙的公式。他说，我们属于“下层上中产阶级”，我们的海外听众会觉得这是你能说出的最典型的英国式表达。但基本上，长话短说，如果我说错了请纠正我，罗伯，这是一个有期望、有某种体面感，但实际上没有钱来维持这种体面的家庭。差不多是这样吗？是的，差不多。当他说“上中产”时，他指的是家庭的文化
ambience and tradition of the family. There's one or two oil paintings floating around. There's a set of leather books, there's cutlery with the family crest on it. But when he says lower, that is upper lower, he means no money. I think there was once a society my flatmate at university's mother was in it called the Society for Distressed Gentlefolk. Although the players weren't quite that, we English know exactly what lower upper middle means. Yeah, old clothes that are fraying he goes to ethan right so i mean he can't be that lower if you're going to eat or am i being naive no well you see tom he's got the culture he's got the upper bit and he goes to prep school he's clever as far as i can make out the family are serious and talk serious.
氛围和传统。周围有一两幅油画。有一套皮装书，有印着家族纹章的餐具。但当他说“下层”，即“上层下中产”时，他指的是没钱。我想曾经有一个协会，我大学室友的母亲就在里面，叫“贫困绅士协会”。虽然布莱尔一家还不至于那样，但我们英国人完全明白“下层上中产”是什么意思。是的，磨损的旧衣服。他去了伊顿公学，对吧？所以，如果你能去伊顿，你不可能那么“下层”，还是我太天真了？不，你看，汤姆，他有文化，他有“上层”的部分，他上了预备学校，他很聪明。据我所知，他的家庭很严肃，谈论的话题也很严肃。
So he's a natural scholarly boy. We should never underestimate his intellectual ability. So he goes to Eton on a scholarship. He is what I think they call a collager rather than an opperdan. And that's how he gets there. A lot of brains, a lot of style, good traditions, but no money. He's a King scholar, which is, you know, that's not nothing. I mean, they live in college,
所以他是一个天生的学者型男孩。我们永远不应低估他的智力。所以他靠奖学金进入了伊顿公学。我想他们称之为“学院生”（collager），而不是“寄宿生”（oppidan）。这就是他进入那里的方式。头脑聪明，有风度，有良好的传统，但没钱。他是国王奖学金获得者，你知道，那可不是小事。我的意思是，他们住在学院里，
which is their own special house for the scholarship boys at Eton. And the Eton thing is really interesting because Orwell is one of the great writers. As Tom knows, I'm obsessed with kind of schools and school stories and all these kinds of things. I think they're so interesting and so formative. And Orwell was one of the great writers about school stories. He very famously wrote this essay about Billy Bunter, who's very much a friend of the rest of his history.
那是伊顿公学为奖学金获得者提供的专属宿舍。伊顿公学的事情真的很有趣，因为奥威尔是一位伟大的作家。正如汤姆所知，我痴迷于学校和校园故事以及所有这些东西。我认为它们非常有趣，而且具有塑造性。奥威尔是描写校园故事的伟大作家之一。他非常著名地写了一篇关于比利·邦特的文章，比利·邦特可是《历史的余味》的好朋友。
A friend of you, I think, Dominic, to be fair. Sorry? A friend of you, to be fair. Is he not a friend of you, Tom? No, I have no time for Billy Bunter. I've never read him. What? time no you've lived to that age you've never read billy bunter this is absolutely outrageous well anyway it's too busy reading about dinosaurs sorry but rob he's really interesting in his relationship with ethan isn't he because the school of obviously very you know to this day very proud of him he writes very damningly about
公平地说，多米尼克，那是你的朋友。抱歉？公平地说，那是你的朋友。汤姆，难道他不是你的朋友吗？不，我没时间看比利·邦特。我从来没读过。什么？你活到这个岁数从来没读过比利·邦特？这简直太离谱了。好吧，反正我太忙于阅读关于恐龙的书了。抱歉，但罗伯，他与伊顿公学的关系真的很有趣，不是吗？因为学校显然至今仍对他非常自豪，而他却写得非常严厉，批评
the world of kind of public schools and all this stuff. And yet, when he left, he went to Old Etonian dinners. He hung around with Old Etonian friends. I mean, right to the end of his life, the Old Etonians were the people who were kind of clustered around him, weren't they? And that sort of goes to one of the contradictions with Orwell, which is that he's both of the kind of British establishment, but also stands outside it and criticizes it. So what's going on there? Well, he's full of contradictions. I mean, we all are, but Orwell rather reveled in them. For him, Eton was never oppressive. I mean, he's against it. He's against it like he's against the Soviet Union. It's a massive thing that he's politically and morally against.
公学世界和所有这些东西。然而，当他离开后，他参加了老伊顿生晚宴。他和老伊顿生的朋友们混在一起。我的意思是，直到他生命的尽头，老伊顿生都是簇拥在他身边的人，不是吗？这触及了奥威尔的一个矛盾，即他既属于英国建制派，又站在建制派之外批评它。这到底是怎么回事？嗯，他充满了矛盾。我的意思是，我们都是如此，但奥威尔相当沉迷于这些矛盾。对他来说，伊顿公学从来不是压迫性的。我的意思是，他反对它。他反对它，就像他反对苏联一样。这是一个他在政治和道德上都反对的庞然大物。
But when you start plumbing Orwell's actual feelings and emotions, then Eaton actually, I think, is not his enemy. It's not his problem. As a collager, he was allowed all kinds of freedoms and liberties to be who he wanted to be. He was clearly known as a bit of a character, a kind of mad geek, a guy who would shock you and appall you at the same time, but then make you laugh. So I think he was not unhappy at Eton where he had the freedom. So he doesn't get kind of bullied by the Toffs for being upper, lower, whatever he is. None of that's going on. No, he doesn't talk kind of bullied by the Toffs for being upper, lower, whatever he is.
但当你开始探究奥威尔真实的感受和情绪时，伊顿公学实际上，我认为，并不是他的敌人。这不是他的问题。作为一名“学院生”，他被允许拥有各种自由和权利去成为他想成为的人。他显然被认为是一个有个性的人，一种疯狂的极客，一个既能让你震惊和厌恶，又能让你发笑的人。所以我认为他在伊顿并不痛苦，在那里他拥有自由。所以他没有因为是“下层上中产”或者其他什么身份而被那些权贵子弟欺负。这些都没有发生。不，他没有谈论
None of that's going on. No, he doesn't talk about that at all. I mean, there are photographs of him playing the Eaton Wall game. He's a big lad. He's actually got shoulders in these photographs. This is before his TB. So he's a big, strong guy. And he's a character. And, you know, people who've got that kind of halo of character around them tend to survive in institutions like that.
这些。不，他根本没谈过这些。我的意思是，有他玩伊顿墙球的照片。他是个大块头。在这些照片里，他甚至有肩膀。这是在他患肺结核之前。所以他是个高大强壮的人。他是个有个性的人。而且，你知道，那些身上带有这种个性光环的人，往往能在那样的机构中生存下来。
The school he hated, the school that which was a fascist institution, according to him, was his prep school. Completely different kind of place, private, money grubbing and hammering the kids to win the scholarships. Eaton was different. Well, his academic record at Eaton was a bit mixed, wasn't it? Because he spent a lot of time, as you say, playing the war game and being a character and writing school newspapers or whatever. So he can't, and his family don't think he'll win a scholarship to university and they can't afford to send him. So he goes for the Imperial Police, doesn't he, in Burma. burma and that's again orwell is one of the
他讨厌的学校，据他说是一个法西斯机构，是他的预备学校。那是完全不同的一种地方，私立、唯利是图，逼着孩子们去赢取奖学金。伊顿则不同。嗯，他在伊顿的学业成绩有点参差不齐，不是吗？因为正如你所说，他花了很多时间玩墙球，做一个有个性的人，写校报之类的。所以他不能，他的家人也不认为他能赢得大学奖学金，他们也负担不起送他去大学的费用。所以他去了缅甸的帝国警察部队，对吧？缅甸，这又是奥威尔作为
great writers who wrestles with the kind of you know the the iniquities or the contradictions of empire and yet here he is as a in his late teens voluntarily choosing to join the imperial police so again is that family pressure or is that there is there something in him that actually quite likes at that stage the idea of empire and the idea of the East and all that sort of stuff? Yeah, I think we've got our finger on him pretty early. There's a big argument about why he didn't go to university. I mean, all his contemporaries did. His girlfriend at the time said he wanted to go, but the parents couldn't afford it.
伟大的作家之一，他与帝国的罪恶或矛盾作斗争，然而他却在十几岁时自愿选择加入帝国警察部队。所以，这又是家庭压力，还是他内心深处在那个阶段实际上相当喜欢帝国的概念、东方的概念以及所有这些东西？是的，我想我们很早就抓住了他的特点。关于他为什么没上大学，有一个很大的争论。我的意思是，他所有的同龄人都上了。他当时的女朋友说他想去，但父母负担不起。
Well, maybe. But I think Orwell just did what he wanted to do, Dominic. If he fancied going to Spain to fight, off he went. If he wanted to go to Wigan, he went to Wigan. If he wanted to live in a bedsit, he lived in a bedsit. He just did it. And there's no sign of his politics in Eton, so I don't think he's going to be anti-imperialist. He wrote a couple of pretty bad poems in favour of the war. He's only a school boy, of course. Mind you, having said that, he's already writing pretty amusing things for the Election Times, which is Eton's newspaper. Pretty good, pretty funny. So he's talented. He has an imperial tradition in the family. I think the prospect of the university
嗯，也许吧。但我认为奥威尔只是做了他想做的事，多米尼克。如果他想去西班牙打仗，他就去了。如果他想去威根，他就去了威根。如果他想住单间公寓，他就住了。他就是这么做了。他在伊顿没有任何政治倾向的迹象，所以我认为他当时不会是反帝国主义者。他写了几首相当糟糕的诗来支持战争。当然，他当时只是个学生。话虽如此，他已经在为《伊顿公学时报》（Eton College Chronicle）写一些相当有趣的东西了。相当不错，相当有趣。所以他很有才华。他家族有帝国传统。我认为大学的前景
might have looked pretty boring to him, actually, compared to Burma and the East and sex and Orientalism and all that. I think he might have wanted to go. Do you think that there was perhaps a kind of strain of perversity that Eton fosters? And so if you become famous as a character at school and you're a character because you are perverse, because you do the things that are the opposite of what everyone else does, perhaps that sets you on a groove that you stick to for the rest of your life. And perhaps if everyone else is going to university, then you go off and join the police or something. It's a marker of how different you are. I think that's right. I mean, I didn't go to public school, but the nearest I came to it
对他来说可能看起来相当无聊，实际上，与缅甸、东方、性和东方主义以及所有这些相比。我想他可能想去。你认为伊顿公学是否培养了一种反常的倾向？如果你在学校里因为有个性而出名，而你的个性是因为你反常，因为你做的事情与其他人相反，也许这让你走上了一条你余生都会坚持的轨道。也许如果其他人都去上大学，那么你就去加入警察部队之类的。这是你与众不同的标志。我认为那是对的。我的意思是，我没上过公学，但我最接近它的经历
was university. I think what happens is when you go to total institutions, it's easier. You find it easier if you have a known persona. And I think he found that at public school, and I think he was seeking to find it too in the empire, as well as all that romance and excitement that the empire, believe it or not, for boys of that type at that time, beckoned. Yeah. Just before we leave Eton, he was taught by Aldous Huxley at Eton, wasn't he? Which is, given the two great prophets, dystopian prophets of the 20th century, that is the most amazing coincidence.
是大学。我认为发生的事情是，当你进入全封闭机构时，这更容易。如果你有一个已知的角色，你会觉得更容易。我认为他在公学发现了这一点，我也认为他在帝国中也在寻求这一点，以及帝国所带来的所有浪漫和兴奋，信不信由你，对于当时那种类型的男孩来说，确实在召唤。是的。在我们离开伊顿之前，他曾由奥尔德斯·赫胥黎在伊顿教过，对吧？考虑到20世纪两位伟大的反乌托邦先知，这真是最令人惊奇的巧合。
And do we know what they thought of each other? I've got some little memory of an exchange in the classroom. I think Huxley was teaching French. He was, yeah. I think he was French. But Orwell was behind the desk. And I've got a vague memory that Huxley wasn't a particularly good teacher
我们知道他们对彼此的看法吗？我记得课堂上有一些交流。我想赫胥黎当时在教法语。他是，是的。我想他是教法语。但奥威尔坐在课桌后面。我模糊地记得赫胥黎并不是一个特别好的老师，
and Orwell was the kind of kid who would let you know about that. But nothing definite, no. Right. So you said about the glamour of the empire. I mean, it's kind of conveyed through schoolboy comics at exactly this age. And that's exactly the kind of subject that Orwell will subsequently write essays about. But when he goes out, famously, he ends up having to shoot an elephant. To what extent is the way he writes about that an actual reflection of what happened?
而奥威尔是那种会让你知道这一点的孩子。但没有确切的证据，没有。好的。所以你谈到了帝国的魅力。我的意思是，它正是通过这个年龄段的校园漫画传达出来的。而这正是奥威尔后来会写文章讨论的主题。但当他走出去时，众所周知，他最终不得不射杀一头大象。他描写这件事的方式在多大程度上是对所发生事情的真实反映？
Or is he self-mythologizing? There's a lot of argument, Tom, about that essay. Did he really shoot an elephant? Or is it a complete metaphor for the empire that is a dying elephant? Or is it a bit of each? Really hard to tell. I don't think we should really worry about it. Like so much of Orwell, I think he's better at the essays than he is at the novels. And this is a stunning, stunning essay on, in a way, how for a young policeman like him, the empire bullies him rather than he bullies the empire. He doesn't want to shoot this elephant. He doesn't know how to shoot this elephant.
还是他在自我神话化？汤姆，关于那篇文章有很多争论。他真的射杀了一头大象吗？还是这完全是帝国作为一个垂死大象的隐喻？还是两者兼而有之？真的很难说。我不认为我们真的应该担心这个问题。像奥威尔的许多作品一样，我认为他在散文方面比在小说方面更好。这是一篇令人惊叹的、令人惊叹的文章，在某种程度上，对于像他这样的年轻警察来说，帝国欺负他，而不是他欺负帝国。他不想射杀这头大象。他不知道如何射杀这头大象。
He has to send for the gun to shoot the elephant. But when he takes aim at the elephant, by the way, a very expensive piece of capital in the Burmese economy, an elephant, and the crowd want him to shoot the elephant. So he has to act like the white man has to act. He has to be brave and fearless and take the elephant down, although he doesn't want to do any of these things. So the point he's making is that the imperialist wears a mask. It's not really him. It's the things, the subject people expect him to be. Yeah, that he's the prisoner of their expectations, isn't he? He's their prisoner rather than they are his prisoner. And there's he's the prisoner of their expectations, isn't he? He's their prisoner
他不得不派人去拿枪来射杀大象。但当他瞄准大象时——顺便说一句，大象是缅甸经济中非常昂贵的资本——人群希望他射杀大象。所以他必须表现得像白人应该表现的那样。他必须勇敢、无畏，把大象打倒，尽管他不想做这些事。所以他提出的观点是，帝国主义者戴着面具。那不是真正的他。那是被统治的人民期望他成为的样子。是的，他是他们期望的囚徒，不是吗？他是他们的囚徒，而不是他们是他的囚徒。而且有
rather than they are his prisoner. And there's about 2000 of them, of course, compared to him on his own, and he's only about 22 or something. So it's a great essay in that sense. There aren't many things I used to get my students to read out aloud in class where they were visibly moved. But I've had students crying while reading that essay. The death of the elephant is really very moving, powerful stuff. He describes what the elephant feels to be shot and to die on its knees. And it's exactly the same descriptions he attaches to his own when he himself is? And this produces the famous essay, Shooting an Elephant, but also the essay, A Hanging, because he has to hang somebody, doesn't he? He's part of a little posse that lead this guy out. And again, hang him in front of a crowd.
大约2000人，当然，相比他一个人，而且他只有22岁左右。所以从这个意义上说，这是一篇伟大的文章。我过去常让学生在课堂上大声朗读的文章并不多，但他们会被明显地感动。我曾有学生在读那篇文章时流泪。大象的死亡确实非常感人，非常有力量。他描述了大象被射中并跪着死去时的感受。这和他自己在他自己是……时所附带的描述完全一样？这产生了著名的文章《射杀大象》，还有文章《绞刑》，因为他必须绞死某人，不是吗？他是带领这个家伙出去的一小队人马的一部分。再一次，在人群面前绞死他。
Is it in front of a crowd, Rob? Well, no, not a crowd. Just a few policemen and officers in a prison yard. He comes back from Burma in 1927. I mean, he's 24 years old. He's only 24, and he's had two lifetimes, Eton College and Burma. He declares to his parents he wants to be a writer. I mean, you can just see the look on their faces. He may as well have said, I want to wear a tutu, really. A tea trick graph on Hus and Hazleton. So he comes back to England and we've got a question from GT Avelado who asks, what was wrong with the name Eric Arthur Blair?
是在人群面前吗，罗伯？嗯，不，不是人群。只是监狱院子里的几个警察和官员。他于1927年从缅甸回来。我的意思是，他24岁。他才24岁，就已经经历了两种人生，伊顿公学和缅甸。他向父母宣布他想成为一名作家。我的意思是，你可以看到他们脸上的表情。他真的还不如说，我想穿芭蕾舞短裙。所以他回到英国，我们收到了GT·阿韦拉多提出的一个问题，他问，埃里克·阿瑟·布莱尔这个名字有什么问题？
Because it's when he comes back to England, isn't it, that he starts to adopt the pseudonym. So why George Orwell? What's wrong with the name he's got? Eric Blair. He adopts it around 1932, 1933. It becomes natural to him, actually, Tom. He ends up signing himself George.
因为当他回到英国时，他开始采用笔名，对吧？那么为什么是乔治·奥威尔？他原来的名字有什么问题？埃里克·布莱尔。他在1932年、1933年左右采用了这个名字。汤姆，这对他来说实际上变得很自然。他最终以乔治的名字签名。
His wife ends up calling him George. But why? Well, we don't know, really. George, St. George, patron saint of England, perhaps? Well, you know, we can do that. We can say a cigar signifies something else. Yes. But the river, is it named after the River Orwell?
他的妻子最终也叫他乔治。但为什么？嗯，我们真的不知道。乔治，圣乔治，英国的守护神，也许？嗯，你知道，我们可以那样做。我们可以说雪茄象征着别的东西。是的。但那条河，它是以奥威尔河命名的吗？
Well, the River Orwell's in Suffolk. His parents are in Suffolk. He loved, he was a great naturalist. He loved the countryside. It's a broad and slow-moving river, very nice image. Some people say he wasn't too keen on the Scots. Therefore, he didn't like the name Blair. Of course, Blair has all kinds of resonances in our own times. But anyway, he dropped it and he went on using both names, Eric Blair and George Orwell, without much thought, really interchangeable. And then he's sort of drifting around, isn't he? I mean, if you look at him, it's quite a long period after his comeback from Burma, when he's sort of tutoring
嗯，奥威尔河在萨福克郡。他的父母在萨福克郡。他热爱，他是一位伟大的博物学家。他热爱乡村。那是一条宽阔而缓慢流动的河流，非常好的意象。有些人说他不太喜欢苏格兰人。因此，他不喜欢布莱尔这个名字。当然，布莱尔在我们这个时代有各种各样的共鸣。但无论如何，他放弃了这个名字，并继续使用这两个名字，埃里克·布莱尔和乔治·奥威尔，没有多想，真的可以互换。然后他有点漂泊不定，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你看看他，在他从缅甸回来后的很长一段时间里，他有点在做家教
and teaching and writing. And when you're young, you're impatient and you feel sort of time slipping away. And actually, he writes these novels in the 1930s that, I mean, frankly, we'll probably skip over them because they're not his best work and they're not much read now. I mean, some people love them, no doubt. But arguably, the book that then makes him is The Road to Wigan Pier. So that's early 1936, Britain in the grip of the Depression. And he goes up north and he writes.
和教书、写作。当你年轻时，你很急躁，你会觉得时间在流逝。实际上，他在20世纪30年代写了这些小说，我的意思是，坦率地说，我们可能会跳过它们，因为它们不是他最好的作品，现在也没人怎么读了。我的意思是，有些人无疑很喜欢它们。但可以说，让他成名的书是《通往威根码头之路》。所以那是1936年初，英国正处于大萧条的控制之下。他去了北方，他写道。
I mean, it's been done already. J.B. Priestley had done it and he writes, I mean, it's been done already. J.B. Priestley had done it, English Journey, a few years earlier. But what is it about that book? I mean, the funny thing, I used to teach that book to my students and they could never get a handle on the fact that the first half was all trudging around mines and sort of working people's houses and saying how simultaneously poor they were, but also cozy and authentic. And then the second half is an attack on middle-class socialists. Well, we'll come to the attack on middle-class socialists. That's a subject after your own heart.
我的意思是，这已经有人做过了。J.B.普里斯特利几年前做过《英国之旅》。但那本书到底有什么特别之处？我的意思是，有趣的是，我过去常给我的学生教那本书，他们永远无法理解这样一个事实：前半部分全是跋涉在矿井和工人的房子里，说他们是多么贫穷，但同时又是多么舒适和真实。然后后半部分是对中产阶级社会主义者的攻击。嗯，我们会谈到对中产阶级社会主义者的攻击。那是一个你非常感兴趣的主题。
But could I just ask another question from Nicola? I can never decide whether Orwell has a genuine empathy for the working classes or whether he saw them as interesting specimens. So what's your take on that? Well, he's actually, he's thrashing around for something to believe in, really. He's a natural contrarian. I think it was Martin Amis called him an auto contrarian. Now there's somebody who gets off by arguing with himself. Hitchens says he's always taking his own temperature. So here's a man arguing endlessly with himself as well as the establishment. But the point is he's looking for something to believe in.
但我能再问一个尼古拉的问题吗？我永远无法决定奥威尔是对工人阶级有真正的同情心，还是他把他们视为有趣的标本。那么你对此有什么看法？嗯，他实际上是在挣扎着寻找可以相信的东西，真的。他是一个天生的反对者。我想是马丁·艾米斯称他为“自动反对者”。现在有人通过与自己争论来获得快感。希钦斯说他总是给自己量体温。所以这是一个不断与自己以及建制派争论的人。但重点是他正在寻找可以相信的东西。
And when he hits the North of England, when he lives with working class people, makes him sound like zoo animals, isn't it? Going to live with working class people, makes him sound like zoo animals, isn't it? Going to live with working class people. When he does that, he finds a part of England and a group of English people he can believe in. And I don't think he's done that before. It's nothing new. You could hardly get on the train north in the 1930s for middle class boys going north to write about how awful it was, but also how authentic it was. And Orwell falls for that.
当他到达英格兰北部，当他与工人阶级住在一起时，这让他听起来像动物园里的动物，不是吗？去和工人阶级住在一起。当他这样做时，他发现了一个他可以相信的英格兰的一部分和一群英国人。我不认为他以前做过那样的事。这没什么新鲜的。在20世纪30年代，你几乎无法登上向北的火车，因为中产阶级男孩们去北方写关于它有多糟糕，但也多真实的文章。奥威尔也迷上了这一点。
But the true point is that here he finds an England to believe in. It's not the England of the Raj. It's not the England of Eton. It's not even the England of down and out in Paris and London or London. This is a group of people, a class, if you will, who he cannot possibly join. He can't do what they do. Why is he in Wigan? He's not there to do any work. He couldn't do the work. So they're valuable in a way he's not valuable. They count
但真正的重点是，在这里他找到了一个可以相信的英格兰。这不是拉吉时代的英格兰。这不是伊顿公学的英格兰。甚至不是《巴黎伦敦落魄记》中的英格兰。这是一群人，如果你愿意的话，一个阶级，他不可能加入。他不能做他们做的事。他为什么在威根？他不是去工作的。他做不了那份工作。所以他们以一种他没有价值的方式有价值。他们算数
in a way he doesn't count. So the first half, Tom wrote the Wig and Peer, tells you how valuable they are. The second part really is telling you how useless he is. He's looking in the mirror and saying, I'm a middle-class socialist, what on earth can we possibly do? Can I quote you? Oh, no. Yeah, go on. Okay. Middle-class socialists, according to Orwell, may speak for the workers. They may go in search of the workers. They may praise the workers, but secretly they dislike the workers for being working class, just as they dislike themselves for being middle-class.
以一种他不算数的方式。所以前半部分，汤姆写的《威根码头之路》，告诉你他们有多有价值。后半部分实际上是在告诉你他有多没用。他看着镜子说，我是一个中产阶级社会主义者，我们到底能做什么？我能引用你的话吗？哦，不。是的，继续。好的。根据奥威尔的说法，中产阶级社会主义者可能会为工人说话。他们可能会去寻找工人。他们可能会赞美工人，但私下里他们讨厌工人是工人阶级，就像他们讨厌自己是中产阶级一样。
Yeah. Well, you obviously do think it's true if you wrote it. So there's all kinds of things to unpack there because, of course, it's in that book as well that Orwell has this passage that when I used to teach it, my students always were shocked by, where he says the working class is smell. He said we were always told, you know, as middle class people,
是的。嗯，如果你写了它，你显然认为它是真的。所以那里有各种各样的事情需要解开，因为当然，也是在那本书里，奥威尔有这段话，当我过去教它时，我的学生总是感到震惊，他说工人阶级有气味。他说我们总是被告知，你知道，作为中产阶级的人，
that the working class is smell, and they do smell. There is a distinctive smell to them, the smell of sweat and dirt and all this kind of thing. And even now people are shocked when they read that, I think. So there is an extent, isn't there, to which he's seen working class people as specimens. But also, do you think there's a self-hatred, a genuine self-hatred? Or is it sort of, to use the jargon, is it performative? Is it put on for literary effect? No, I don't think it's real self-hatred. I don't think he wants to, I mean, he says somewhere in argument that to disembouchoisify himself, that is to cease to be middle class, would be to kill himself. And what sensible person would ever want to do that he's got to live with himself there were
工人阶级有气味，而且他们确实有气味。他们有一种独特的气味，汗水和污垢以及所有这些东西的气味。即使现在人们读到那段话时也会感到震惊，我想。所以，在某种程度上，他确实把工人阶级视为标本，不是吗？但你认为有一种自我厌恶，一种真正的自我厌恶吗？还是说，用行话来说，它是表演性的？它是为了文学效果而装出来的吗？不，我不认为那是真正的自我厌恶。我不认为他想，我的意思是，他在某个争论中说，要“去资产阶级化”自己，也就是不再是中产阶级，那将是自杀。任何理智的人怎么会想那样做呢？他必须和自己住在一起。有
writers at the time who said you know you had to atone for your class background and and and really hollow yourself out and start again this is terrible news to all well he's not going to do that the road to Wigan Pier says that I am who I am but at the same time he does see these people these amazing valuable people in his eyes he's see these people, these amazing, valuable people in his eyes. He's never seen people like that before. He's never even been to the north of England before, except once briefly to see his sister. So he's never rather, you might say he's never breathed in and smelt the air up there. And now he has, and he thinks it's interesting and valuable. So yes, they are specimens in one sense, and he doesn't see all of their lives.
当时的作家说，你知道，你必须为你的阶级背景赎罪，并且真正地掏空自己，重新开始。这对奥威尔来说是可怕的消息。他不会那样做。《通往威根码头之路》说，我就是我，但与此同时，他确实看到了这些人，这些在他眼中令人惊叹的、有价值的人。他以前从未见过这样的人。他甚至以前从未去过英格兰北部，除了有一次短暂地去看望他的姐姐。所以他从未，或者说，你可能会说他从未呼吸过和闻过那里的空气。现在他闻到了，他认为这很有趣且有价值。所以是的，从某种意义上说，他们是标本，而且他并没有看到他们生活的全部。
He tends to just see the downside of their lives. The good side of their lives he rather misses. I mean, he's in Wigan. Does he go and see the rugby? No. He's in Barnsley. Does he go and see the football? No.
他倾向于只看到他们生活的阴暗面。他们生活的好的一面他反而错过了。我的意思是，他在威根。他去看橄榄球了吗？没有。他在巴恩斯利。他去看足球了吗？没有。
But nevertheless, he's a fair person, and he's trying to deal with fair questions. He goes to the North thinking that the unemployed are the problem and socialism is the answer. And he comes back from the North thinking the unemployed are the answer and socialism is the problem. Well, this thing about socialism being the problem. I mean, he has these absolutely, you know, these famous lines, which as somebody who spent his life working in universities, you'll be very familiar with, that socialism and left-wing ideas tend to attract every fruit juice drinker, nudist, sandal wearer, and sex maniac in England. Now that really offended, it still offends people, actually, when I, you know, every couple of weeks when i when i put it in the
但尽管如此，他是一个公平的人，他正在努力处理公平的问题。他去北方时认为失业者是问题，社会主义是答案。他从北方回来时认为失业者是答案，社会主义是问题。嗯，关于社会主义是问题这件事。我的意思是，他有这些绝对的，你知道，这些名言，作为一个人一生都在大学工作的人，你会非常熟悉，社会主义和左翼思想倾向于吸引英国每一个喝果汁的人、裸体主义者、穿凉鞋的人和性狂。现在这真的冒犯了，它仍然冒犯了人们，实际上，当我，你知道，每隔几周当我把它放进
daily mail and i dig out those lines and put them in britain's most beloved newspaper you know people get very sort of academic people weep and wail and kind of rent their garments you know in misery because they they say oh this is true this is orwell was a dreadful man. You know, he sneering. But they don't, though, do they? High-minded. That's the thing. Some people do. They don't. Some people do, Tom.
《每日邮报》并且我挖出那些台词并把它们放进英国最受喜爱的报纸时，你知道，人们变得非常，学术界的人们哭泣和哀号，并以某种方式撕裂他们的衣服，你知道，在痛苦中，因为他们说，哦，这是真的，这是奥威尔是一个可怕的人。你知道，他冷嘲热讽。但他们没有，不是吗？高尚。这就是重点。有些人确实。他们没有。有些人确实，汤姆。
I mean, Orwell said terribly politically incorrect things about gay people, about Jews, about all kinds of people. But he hasn't – I mean, he remains a kind of sainted figure pretty much across the political spectrum. He's uncancellable, you think? Pretty much, yeah. Wouldn't you say? Maybe time will tell, I don't know. Or is he uncancellable, or do you think there are sort of high-minded people who shudder at the very mention of his name?
我的意思是，奥威尔对同性恋者、犹太人、各种各样的人说了非常政治不正确的话。但他没有——我的意思是，他仍然是一个在政治光谱中几乎被圣化的人物。你认为他是不可取消的吗？差不多，是的。你不觉得吗？也许时间会证明，我不知道。或者他是不可取消的，还是你认为有一些高尚的人在提到他的名字时会不寒而栗？
I think you're both right, actually. I think everybody gets the Orwell they deserve. And it's not difficult to be shocked and surprised by him. But on the other hand, whenever a journalist is looking for a bit of moral firepower, bang, in goes Orwell. It happens every day, even in the mail. He was right about the sandalware. I mean, just on the topic of where Orwell stood politically, if I understand you right, basically, I mean, he's ultimately, he's not responding to political opinions. He's responding to kind of gut instincts within himself. Would that be fair? And so to that extent, perhaps he doesn't, you know, it would be wrong to pin him down. So we have a question from a former Labour councillor who is a firm believer in the divine right of kings, who goes by the name of Capple Loft on Twitter. And he asks,
我认为你们两个都对，实际上。我认为每个人都得到了他们应得的奥威尔。被他震惊和惊讶并不难。但另一方面，每当记者寻找一点道德火力时，砰，奥威尔就进去了。这每天都在发生，即使在《每日邮报》也是如此。关于穿凉鞋的人，他是对的。我的意思是，就在奥威尔政治立场的话题上，如果我没理解错的话，基本上，我的意思是，他最终不是在回应政治观点。他是在回应他内心深处的直觉。这公平吗？所以在这个程度上，也许他没有，你知道，把他钉死是不对的。所以我们有一个来自前工党议员的问题，他是一位坚定的君权神授信徒，在推特上叫Capple Loft。他问，
is it true that Orwell was a conservative in feeling and a radical in politics? Some would say a Tory socialist. So I suspect that Capple Loft is basically saying, was Orwell like Capple Loft? Yeah. Well, he called himself a Tory anarchist and a bit of banter around the Adelphi offices. I think it's not a bad definition, actually. I think in his soul, he was not a revolutionary. He did not want to abolish the past. I refer your listeners to your superb program on Mao's Cultural Revolution. He loved the past because it's where his world and our world was made, for better or worse.
奥威尔在感觉上是保守派，在政治上是激进派，这是真的吗？有些人会说是“托利社会主义者”。所以我怀疑Capple Loft基本上是在说，奥威尔像Capple Loft吗？是的。嗯，他称自己为“托利无政府主义者”，在阿德尔菲办公室周围有一些玩笑。我认为这实际上不是一个坏定义。我认为在他的灵魂深处，他不是一个革命者。他不想废除过去。我请你的听众参考你们关于毛泽东文化大革命的精彩节目。他热爱过去，因为那是我们的世界和他的世界被创造的地方，无论好坏。
But at the same time, he was an anti-establishment in the way he had been at Eton. He couldn't resist pot-shotting at the mighty, the vain, the venal. He loved history. He loved tradition. When he writes about public schools, as Dominic said, he writes with love, actually. But his politics are his rational universe. And he potshots at public schools, rich people, corporations, and so on. I mean, I don't think he's unlike a lot of us. We have the things we love and know best and don't want them changed, but we know there are things that need changing. The question is, how do we avoid changing ourselves by changing the world around us? Yeah. And maybe in that, he really does speak for a very, very important strain within England, certainly perhaps Britain.
但与此同时，他是一个反建制派，就像他在伊顿公学时那样。他无法抗拒对权贵、虚荣、贪婪的人进行抨击。他热爱历史。他热爱传统。当他写公学时，正如多米尼克所说，他实际上是带着爱写的。但他的政治是他理性的宇宙。他抨击公学、富人、公司等等。我的意思是，我不认为他不像我们许多人。我们有我们最爱和最了解的东西，不想改变它们，但我们知道有些东西需要改变。问题是，我们如何避免通过改变周围的世界来改变我们自己？是的。也许在这一点上，他确实代表了英格兰，当然也许是英国，一个非常、非常重要的倾向。
And perhaps that's why he has such a significant status. But that word England is central there, isn't it? I mean, your book, Rob, talks about all while in Englishness. writers, certainly the first 20th century writers, to really grapple with the idea of England and Englishness having a distinctive kind of cultural and political meaning, that it's all about the concrete and little things. And that famous passage that I read out on our podcast that we did with Jason Cowley, Tom, the grass is greener, the beer is bitterer, the ugly faces, the money, all of that stuff.
也许这就是为什么他有如此重要的地位。但“英格兰”这个词在那里是核心，不是吗？我的意思是，你的书，罗伯，谈到了奥威尔的英国性。作家，当然是20世纪初的作家，真正抓住英格兰和英国性具有独特的文化和政治意义的想法，即它全是关于具体和微小的事物。以及我在我们和杰森·考利做的播客中读到的那段著名的段落，汤姆，草更绿，啤酒更苦，丑陋的脸，钱，所有这些东西。
I mean, do you think he's – so in those days, when he was writing, people equated England and Britain. I mean, they did it all the time. But do you think he's really – it's all about England and Englishness rather than Britain and Britishness for him? He writes unashamedly about England, something difficult to do now and was even difficult then because England was supposed to carry the weight of the United Kingdom. And England was big and rich and powerful.
我的意思是，你认为他是——所以在那些日子里，当他写作时，人们把英格兰和英国等同起来。我的意思是，他们一直这样做。但你认为他真的是——对他来说，这全是关于英格兰和英国性，而不是英国和不列颠性吗？他毫无顾忌地写英格兰，这在现在很难做到，即使在当时也很难，因为英格兰被认为要承担联合王国的重量。而英格兰又大、又富、又强大。
And if it rolled over in bed, it could squeeze you or squash you or roll you out. So England had to stay like, if you like, it had to sleep quietly. Nowadays, it's rather different. It's difficult to be unashamedly English because England stands for all kinds of iniquities and oppressions and imperialisms that some of us are not happy about. But he was different. He was a Republican at heart. And that's why he's a great essayist. The essay is the great instrument of the Republic. And he writes and speaks and feels freely about being English. And I find that really liberating. But it's not in a capital P political way. As you say, Dom, he starts with the details. He starts with the little things. And he also tries to get things right. If we are conservative in one sense and radical in another, he deals with that, or at least he tries to. Well, Rob, you said that Orwell was a Republican at heart. And of course, he goes out to Spain to fight for the Republicans in the Spanish Civil War. I think we should take
如果它在床上翻身，它可能会挤压你、压扁你或把你滚下去。所以英国必须保持，如果你愿意的话，它必须安静地睡觉。如今，情况大不相同了。很难做到毫无愧疚地做一个英国人，因为英国代表了我们中一些人并不乐见的各种不义、压迫和帝国主义。但他不同。他内心是一个共和主义者。这就是为什么他是一位伟大的散文家。散文是共和国的伟大工具。他自由地写作、谈论和感受作为英国人的身份。我觉得这真的很令人解放。但这并不是大写的“政治”意义上的。正如你所说，多姆，他从细节入手。他从细微之处着手。而且他也试图把事情做好。如果我们一方面是保守的，另一方面是激进的，他会处理这个问题，或者至少他会尝试。好吧，罗伯，你说奥威尔内心是一个共和主义者。当然，他去了西班牙，在西班牙内战中为共和派而战。我想我们应该休息一下。
a break. But when we come back, perhaps we could talk about that and then about the Republicans in the Spanish Civil War. I think we should take a break, but when we come back, perhaps we could talk about that and then about the impact of the Second World War as well and look at Animal Farm and 1984. So we'll be back in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
休息一下。但当我们回来时，也许我们可以谈谈那个，然后谈谈西班牙内战中的共和派。我想我们应该休息一下，但当我们回来时，也许我们可以谈谈那个，然后谈谈第二次世界大战的影响，并看看《动物庄园》和《1984》。所以我们一会儿回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻固定节目，
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest is History. We are talking George Orwell with Robert Coles,
评论，还有一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在与罗伯特·科尔斯讨论乔治·奥威尔，
Professor Robert Coles, I should say. So Orwell is just about to go off to Spain. It's December 1936. Rob, off he goes. And he joins the PUM, the, what is it? The Partida Obrero de Unificación Marxista. So it's a Trotskyist. I hope everybody enjoyed my Spanish
罗伯特·科尔斯教授，我应该这么说。所以奥威尔正要动身去西班牙。那是1936年12月。罗伯，他出发了。他加入了统一马克思主义工人党（POUM），那个，是什么来着？Partida Obrero de Unificación Marxista。所以这是一个托洛茨基主义组织。我希望大家喜欢我的西班牙语
pronunciation. Muy bien. So it's a Trotskyist group, isn't it? I mean, what's he doing? Because obviously a lot of people do go out to fight in Spain. Is he trying to prove something to himself? Is he genuinely motivated by ideological fervor? What's going on? Well, the first thing that's going on is that he's leaving his wife of only six months. I must mention Eileen O'Shaughnessy, who he marries in June 1936 in Wallington. So he's hardly, you know, he's married six months, they're living in a little cottage and just, he goes, he just wants to go. Why he goes is a bit more tricky, says he wants to kill fascists, but it might be that he wants to write. It may be that
发音。非常好。所以这是一个托洛茨基主义组织，对吧？我的意思是，他在做什么？因为显然很多人确实去西班牙打仗。他是在向自己证明什么吗？他是真的被意识形态的热情所驱动吗？到底发生了什么？嗯，首先发生的是他离开了他结婚才六个月的妻子。我必须提到艾琳·奥肖内西，他在1936年6月在沃灵顿与她结婚。所以他几乎，你知道，他结婚才六个月，他们住在一个小木屋里，然后他就走了，他只是想去。他为什么去有点复杂，他说他想杀法西斯分子，但可能他想写作。可能
he wants to do what's really, he's itching to do, that is be an active correspondent. I mean, all his instincts are about the detail, about being there. He wants to be there. So he goes to Paris, sees Henry Miller briefly, takes the train across France with other soldiers of the revolution traveling to Spain. The peasants stand up in the fields and straighten their backs and put their fist sign against the soldiers going south on the trains. He absolutely loves this. And arrives in Barcelona, where he finds what he thinks is a socialist or maybe a social anarchist society, but at least a free one. And he can't believe how wonderful things seem. And as you say, he joins this militia group
他想做他真正渴望做的事情，那就是成为一名活跃的通讯员。我的意思是，他所有的本能都是关于细节，关于身临其境。他想去那里。所以他去了巴黎，简短地见了亨利·米勒，和其他革命士兵一起乘火车穿过法国前往西班牙。农民们在田野里站起来，挺直腰杆，向乘火车南下的士兵举起拳头。他非常喜欢这个。并抵达巴塞罗那，在那里他发现了在他看来是社会主义或者可能是社会无政府主义的社会，但至少是一个自由的社会。他简直不敢相信事情看起来有多么美好。正如你所说，他加入了这个民兵组织
through the offices of the Independent Labour Party where he has connections. And then it all goes wrong quite quickly, doesn't it? Because he's only been there a few months and the Republicans are torn apart by faction fighting. The communists basically, you know, because the Republican cause is becoming increasingly dependent on Stalin and the Soviet Union. So the communists turn on the poom in the May days in Barcelona. And I get the
通过独立工党的办公室，他在那里有关系。然后一切很快就变糟了，不是吗？因为他才在那里待了几个月，共和派就被派系斗争撕裂了。共产党基本上，你知道，因为共和派的事业越来越依赖斯大林和苏联。所以共产党在巴塞罗那的五月事变中转向了统一马克思主义工人党（POUM）。我得到
impression, and now maybe this is me misreading it, that that is a massive moment in Orwell's life, this sense of betrayal by the communists, because of course, he then becomes famous as probably the single most, well, one of the most famous British anti-communist writers. So do you think that was a transformative moment, what happened in May 1937? Yeah, definitely. I mean, Spain is massive for him. It's a defining experience. He sees blood there and some of it's his own. And he is wrecked, really. His health is seriously wrecked there. And so are his little green shoots of socialism or even Marxism that might have been sprouting a little bit in Wigan, because what he sees is a republic dominated by the Soviet Union, who are the only foreign power supplying the Republic with tanks and weapons, but dominated. And far from the
印象，也许是我误读了，那是奥威尔生命中的一个重大时刻，这种被共产党背叛的感觉，因为当然，他后来成为了可能最著名的，嗯，最著名的英国反共作家之一。所以你认为那是具有变革意义的时刻吗，1937年5月发生的事情？是的，绝对是。我的意思是，西班牙对他来说意义重大。这是一个决定性的经历。他在那里看到了血，其中一些是他自己的。他真的被摧毁了。他的健康在那里受到了严重损害。他在威根可能刚刚萌芽的一点点社会主义甚至马克思主义的嫩芽也被摧毁了，因为他所看到的是一个由苏联主导的共和国，苏联是唯一向共和国提供坦克和武器的外国势力，但却是主导。而且远非
Soviet Union being too revolutionary for Orwell, it's not revolutionary enough. He thinks it's suppressing the revolution, whereas it should be unleashing it. But the real problem he has is not with the Soviet Union, which is something of an abstraction from where Orwell's standing on the front line. His real problem is with the people on the left in England who are pro-Soviet. And that's where his anger and his sense of revenge really comes. So when he gets back to England, he goes into a writing frenzy against the left, the soft left and the hard left. And of course, out of that frenzy comes Homage to Catalonia, which I think he always regarded as his greatest book. And Rob, also, when he comes back, he talks about the deep sleep of England, doesn't he,
苏联对奥威尔来说太激进，它还不够激进。他认为它在压制革命，而它本应释放革命。但他真正的问题不在于苏联，对于站在前线的奥威尔来说，苏联是一个抽象的概念。他真正的问题在于英国那些亲苏的左派。这就是他的愤怒和复仇感真正来源的地方。所以当他回到英国时，他陷入了针对左派、温和左派和激进左派的写作狂潮。当然，在那场狂潮中诞生了《向加泰罗尼亚致敬》，我认为他一直将其视为他最伟大的书。罗伯，还有，当他回来时，他谈到了英国的沉睡，不是吗，
from which it will only be woken by bombs so presumably he in saying that he has a sense that war will be coming to britain and what is his attitude to britain at the time that the second world war breaks out because he's there's been an element of hatred there of hostility of of of dislike for it is that turning to love by the time that the Second World War begins or does it remain a kind of love-hate relationship? Well, politically, he's really confused in this period, 37 to 39. In his position, he takes the Poon position on Spain and just applies it wholesale, slaps it on Britain and Germany. He basically says, unless you fight Germany and revolt against the ruling class, you can't win the war.
它只有被炸弹惊醒，所以大概他在说这话时，他有一种战争即将来到英国的感觉，当第二次世界大战爆发时，他对英国的态度是什么？因为那里一直存在着一种仇恨、敌意、不喜欢，当第二次世界大战开始时，这种态度是否正在转变为爱，还是它仍然是一种爱恨交织的关系？嗯，在政治上，他在这个时期（37年到39年）真的很困惑。在西班牙问题上，他采取了POUM的立场，并将其全盘应用，强加在英国和德国身上。他基本上说，除非你与德国作战并反抗统治阶级，否则你无法赢得战争。
So war and revolution go together. So he envisages, you know, London in 1940, the English fighting each other while they're fighting the Germans who are trying to kill them. I mean, it's a completely messed up, trashy, Marxist tactical position. And he can't really deal with it. It doesn't go anywhere. At one point, he's actually anti-war. He lines up with the Independent Labour Party and the
所以战争和革命是并行的。所以他设想，你知道，1940年的伦敦，英国人在与试图杀死他们的德国人作战的同时，也在互相残杀。我的意思是，这是一个完全搞砸了的、垃圾的马克思主义战术立场。他真的无法处理它。它没有任何进展。有一次，他实际上是反战的。他与独立工党和
Peace Pledge Union with their pacifism or a form of pacifism. But the point about England and the English is he gets himself straight when at some point in 1939, in the declaration of war, he sees that the people are up for this. Didn't think they would be. They are. There's no panic. There's no shock. There's no enthusiasm either. They're just getting on with it. In Churchill's words, it's just K-B-O. And he aligns with that. He thinks it's real and he thinks it's necessary. And so what is Orwell's own role in the war? Well, he tries to join up. As soon as war is declared, he puts himself forward for the army, but his health is wrecked by then. He doesn't pass the fitness test. He doesn't know what to do. He tries to get an apprenticeship as
和平誓言联盟及其和平主义或某种形式的和平主义站在了一起。但关于英国和英国人的重点是，他在1939年的某个时候，在宣战时，他理清了自己的思路，他看到人们已经准备好迎接这一切了。没想到他们会这样。他们确实准备好了。没有恐慌。没有震惊。也没有热情。他们只是在继续生活。用丘吉尔的话说，就是“保持冷静，继续前进”（KBO）。他与此保持一致。他认为这是真实的，他认为这是必要的。那么奥威尔在战争中扮演了什么角色呢？嗯，他试图参军。战争一宣布，他就报名参军，但那时他的健康状况已经被摧毁了。他没有通过体能测试。他不知道该做什么。他试图获得一个学徒职位，作为
a fitter in the factory, a machinist. Doesn't get that. Does a lot of reviews of theatre and cinema. He's embarrassed, deeply embarrassed about that. He tries to join the intelligence corps. He gets nowhere there. They've been watching him for a few years, not him watching others. So in the end, he moves to London in 1940, and he joins what were then called the local defence volunteers, later to become the Home Guard, where he rises through the ranks to sergeant. Private Pike. Sergeant Wilson. He loves it. He loves the Home Guard. And it seems his platoon pretty much liked him.
工厂里的装配工，机械师。没得到。做了很多戏剧和电影评论。他对此感到尴尬，非常尴尬。他试图加入情报部队。他在那里一无所获。他们已经监视他几年了，而不是他监视别人。所以最后，他在1940年搬到了伦敦，加入了当时被称为地方防御志愿者（LDV）的组织，后来成为国土卫队（Home Guard），他在那里晋升为中士。派克列兵。威尔逊中士。他喜欢它。他喜欢国土卫队。而且看起来他的排相当喜欢他。
After all, he knew about street fighting. Because he'd been shot in the throat, hadn't he, in Spain, as you said, and nearly killed. So, I mean, he's a useful man to have in your dad's army platoon. Well, he has a paramilitary background, Dom. I mean, the police in Burma were not bobbies on the beat, you know. I mean, this was a paramilitary force. So he knew about that. And he knew about street fighting from Spain. And along with a guy called Tom Winteringham, who was a left winger in 1939-40, he even thought that maybe the Home Guard could become a British militia, that it could have revolutionary instincts.
毕竟，他了解巷战。因为正如你所说，他在西班牙喉部中弹，差点丧命。所以，我的意思是，他是一个在你父亲的军队排里很有用的人。嗯，他有准军事背景，多姆。我的意思是，缅甸的警察不是街上的巡警，你知道。我的意思是，这是一支准军事部队。所以他了解这一点。而且他从西班牙了解巷战。和一个叫汤姆·温特林汉姆的人一起，他是1939-40年的左翼分子，他甚至认为国土卫队可能成为一支英国民兵，它可能具有革命本能。
I mean, after all, here you have the people who are armed. And although in one sense, that's a real sign of the virtues of democracy. You can arm the people. On the other hand, Orwell and Winteringham seem to think it might be political. It might become political. But either way, he was a useful guy to have around. Yeah. As late as the autumn of 1940, he's writing,
我的意思是，毕竟，这里有武装的人民。虽然在某种意义上，这是民主美德的真正标志。你可以武装人民。另一方面，奥威尔和温特林汉姆似乎认为这可能是政治性的。它可能变得政治化。但无论如何，他是一个值得拥有的人。是的。直到1940年秋天，他还在写，
I dare say the London gutters will have to run with blood when the Red militias are billeted at the Ritz. So that's still percolating away in his mind, even as he's signing up to the Home Guard and all that kind of stuff. I think that's Lion and the Unicorn. That's 41. That means the old Poon tactical position of 37 is still operating in his mind in 41.
“我敢说，当红色民兵驻扎在丽兹酒店时，伦敦的阴沟里将流淌着鲜血。”所以即使在他加入国土卫队等等的时候，这仍然在他的脑海中酝酿。我想那是《狮子与独角兽》。那是41年的作品。这意味着37年的旧POUM战术立场在41年仍然在他的脑海中运作。
And it's not really till 42 that he sheds himself of it. He admits that he got it hopelessly wrong. And actually, the people were miles ahead of him. Even Churchill was ahead of him. This was a war that had to be taken on and fought to the finish. And the less you talked about revolution within that war, the better. Well, I was going to ask, when does he start working for the Ministry of Truth, aka the BBC? 41. And is the Ministry of Truth modelled on the BBC? Because that's what I always thought,
直到42年他才真正摆脱它。他承认他错得离谱。实际上，人民比他领先了数英里。甚至丘吉尔也领先于他。这是一场必须承担并战斗到底的战争。而且你在那场战争中谈论革命越少越好。嗯，我正要问，他什么时候开始为真理部，也就是BBC工作？41年。真理部是以BBC为原型的吗？因为我一直这么认为，
but probably that's not true. Well, actually, people often say the Ministry of Truth modelled on the BBC? Because that's what I always thought, but probably that's not true. Well, actually, people often say the Ministry of Truth was based on Senate House in London, which was never the BBC. And he never worked at the BBC headquarters either. He worked, which you two guys know pretty well, he worked in Oxford Street where they'd rented premises. But nevertheless, I mean, he called the BBC a frightful bureaucracy. It was his first introduction to bureaucracy, after all.
但那可能不是真的。嗯，实际上，人们经常说真理部是以BBC为原型的？因为我一直这么认为，但那可能不是真的。嗯，实际上，人们经常说真理部是以伦敦的参议院大厦为基础的，那从来都不是BBC。而且他也没有在BBC总部工作过。他工作的地方，你们两个家伙很清楚，他在牛津街工作，他们租了那里的房产。但尽管如此，我的意思是，他称BBC为一个可怕的官僚机构。毕竟，这是他第一次接触官僚机构。
It is. Well, yeah, he's not wrong, to be fair, Rob. I mean, this was a guy who'd never held down a proper job, you know, but now he had one. Well, that's like me and Tom. But going back to the politics of the war. So at about that point, obviously, I mean, this great irony of the Second World War, that Britain finds itself allied to the one power that Orwell really detests, that he has a problem with, which is Stalin's Soviet Union.
确实。嗯，是的，说实话，罗伯，他没说错。我的意思是，这是一个从未从事过正经工作的人，你知道，但现在他有了一份。嗯，那就像我和汤姆。但回到战争的政治。所以在大约那个时候，显然，我的意思是，第二次世界大战的这个巨大讽刺，英国发现自己与奥威尔真正厌恶的、他有问题的一个大国结盟，那就是斯大林的苏联。
And so when is it? 1943, that he starts writing Animal Farm. really the high point of our romance of Uncle Joe and the plucky Russians and all that sort of thing. So he's obviously thinking about Animal Farm as a warning, presumably. And do you think it's born of his shock that, you know, so many people are rushing to kind of embrace the Soviet cause, do you think? Or do you think it was always coming anyway, Animal Farm, because of Spain? Well, he never talks about his writing plans, Dominic. We never really know how he's shaping things.
所以是什么时候？1943年，他开始写《动物庄园》。真的是我们对“乔叔叔”和勇敢的俄罗斯人等等的浪漫情怀的最高点。所以他显然是在把《动物庄园》当作一个警告，大概是这样。你认为它是出于他的震惊吗，你知道，这么多人急于拥抱苏联事业，你认为它是吗？还是你认为《动物庄园》无论如何都会出现，因为西班牙？嗯，他从不谈论他的写作计划，多米尼克。我们从来不知道他是如何塑造事物的。
He never talks about how he writes or his plans. The right things just appear. Even his agent really doesn't know what he's doing until he's done it. But in retrospect, you know, he said he thought of Animal Farm when he was in Wallington and he saw a little boy whacking a shire horse along the lane. And he thought, what if that shire horse just turned on the little boy with one great hoof and put him down? What's it about? Well, it's not just about the Soviet Union, I think. I think it's about revolution and how it invariably leads to a vacuum and the vacuum leads to another kind of ruling elite, which may well be worse than the one you replace. I think it's a warning about
他从不谈论他是如何写作或他的计划。正确的东西只是出现了。甚至他的经纪人直到他完成之前都不知道他在做什么。但回想起来，你知道，他说他想到《动物庄园》是在沃灵顿的时候，他看到一个小男孩在巷子里鞭打一匹夏尔马。他想，如果那匹夏尔马用一只巨大的蹄子转向小男孩并把他放倒会怎样？它是关于什么的？嗯，我认为它不仅仅是关于苏联。我认为它是关于革命以及它如何总是导致真空，而真空导致另一种统治精英，这可能比你取代的那个更糟。我认为这是一个关于
revolutions in general, rather than just the Soviet Union. When he was pressed on it, he's actually rather surprisingly mild about his intentions regarding the Soviet Union. He says, well, the Soviet Union's got its problems. They're not my problems directly. I don't really want to get involved in that. My real aim with Animal Farm is to warn the British that the Soviet Union's no model, that we must find our own way and we mustn't stop looking to Russia because it's destroying the hope of real genuine socialism here. But the fascinating thing about Animal Farm is that he struggles to get it published because so many British publishers, they say, you know, we're in bed with the Russians, so
革命的普遍警告，而不仅仅是关于苏联。当他被追问时，他实际上对他关于苏联的意图表现得相当温和。他说，嗯，苏联有它的问题。那不是我直接的问题。我真的不想卷入其中。我写《动物庄园》的真正目的是警告英国人，苏联不是榜样，我们必须找到自己的路，我们不能停止关注俄罗斯，因为它正在摧毁这里真正社会主义的希望。但《动物庄园》迷人的地方在于，他很难出版它，因为许多英国出版商说，你知道，我们和俄罗斯人是一伙的，所以
we don't want to publish it. So for example, Victor Galantz, who he'd worked with, T.S. Eliot of Faber and Faber says, it's jolly good, but we don't want to do it. He ends up doing it with Wahlberg. And then of course the CIA take it up, don't they? And they later drop copies by balloon into occupied Europe. And I guess the question really is, is it a right-wing book, do you think? And ultimately, because of the, I mean, that warning about revolution, as you say, I mean, that's classic Edmund Burke, isn't it? Don't tear it all down because, sorry, Tom, you've got a question. Yeah, we've got a question from Tim Fasby-Burney, a top vicar, and he would love to know the public
我们不想出版它。例如，他曾与之共事的维克多·戈兰茨，费伯出版社的T.S.艾略特说，这很好，但我们不想做。他最终和沃尔伯格一起做了。当然，中央情报局接手了，不是吗？他们后来用气球把副本投放到被占领的欧洲。我想真正的问题是，你认为这是一本右翼书籍吗？最终，因为那个，我的意思是，关于革命的警告，正如你所说，我的意思是，那是经典的埃德蒙·伯克，不是吗？不要把它全部拆掉，因为，抱歉，汤姆，你有一个问题。是的，我们有一个来自蒂姆·法斯比-伯尼的问题，一位高级牧师，他很想知道公众
reaction to Orwell's books. For example, did Animal Farm cause anti-communist feelings to rise? How is it received by communist supporters in Britain? The reaction in Britain, the reviews are great, except for predictably, you know, the Daily Worker and communist reviews are not great. They're cruel. And they say it's a disgraceful, treacherous work. But he doesn't seem to care about that. Dominic's right, he had great trouble getting it published, not just from left publishers, but also from right-wing publishers like Faber and Faber, where T.S. Eliot ruled the roost. There were even communist agents advising publishers from the British Ministry of Information, advising them not to
对奥威尔书籍的反应。例如，《动物庄园》是否引起了反共情绪的上升？它在英国的共产主义支持者中是如何被接受的？在英国的反应，评论很好，除了可以预见的是，你知道，《每日工人报》和共产主义评论并不好。它们很残酷。他们说这是一部可耻的、背叛的作品。但他似乎并不在乎。多米尼克是对的，他出版它遇到了很大的困难，不仅来自左翼出版商，也来自像费伯出版社这样的右翼出版商，T.S.艾略特在那里说了算。甚至有共产主义特工建议英国新闻部的出版商，建议他们不要
publish. These guys later turned out to be communist agents. So this went rather deep in Orwell. He knew that communism was a bad idea, but now he knew that it infiltrated and it worked by deceit and deception. And of course, this has great influence on 1984. It's a populist work, actually, Tom, if you really want my opinion about it. There are no left-wing intellectuals in it, really. There's just the people, the animals who are good. Yes, and the pigs who end up more equal than everyone else and basically become humans, don't they? So Old Major is a kind of intellectual, isn't he? Is he a combination of Marx and Lenin? Is that the...
出版。这些人后来被证明是共产主义特工。所以这对奥威尔的影响相当深远。他知道共产主义是个坏主意，但现在他知道它渗透了，它是通过欺骗和诡计运作的。当然，这对《1984》有很大的影响。汤姆，如果你真的想听我的意见，这是一部民粹主义作品。里面真的没有左翼知识分子。只有人民，那些好的动物。是的，还有那些最终变得比其他人更平等，基本上变成了人类的猪，不是吗？所以老少校是一种知识分子，不是吗？他是马克思和列宁的结合体吗？那是……
I don't think he's Lenin. I mean, he's not what you might call dynamic. No. Old Major's a prize ball. I don't know if there's a pun there. He's exhibited... Very good. He's exhibited as Willingdon beauty. I mean, there's some respect there. Anyone who calls a pig Willington Beauty must have some respect for pigs. But I think in the end, once a pig, always a pig. So Animal Farm comes out just after the government has come to power and the end of the war. And Orwell then starts on 1984. And the opening of that book that I read,
我不认为他是列宁。我的意思是，他不是你所说的充满活力的人。不。老少校是一头获奖公猪。我不知道那里是否有双关语。他被展示为……非常好。他被展示为“威灵顿美人”。我的意思是，那里有一些尊重。任何称猪为“威灵顿美人”的人一定对猪有一些尊重。但我认为最终，猪永远是猪。所以《动物庄园》是在政府上台和战争结束后不久出版的。奥威尔随后开始了《1984》。我读的那本书的开头，
The Hallway Smelt of Boiled Cabbage and Old Rag Mats, we did an episode on Agatha Christie, where we talked about Agatha Christie's novels holding a mirror up to the era of the Attlee government. And there's a sense, isn't there, in which 1984 is a satire on Atlee's government as much as it is anything. That kind of climate of austerity, of controls. And it's quite a kind of... Am I being unfair there? I think so, yeah. I think I just recently read Keith Richard of the Rolling Stones memoir of post-war London. And what Keith Richard remembers about the potholes and the smashed buildings and the rubbishy cigarettes and all the rest of it is it's there in 1984. It's an account of London damaged, a damaged city. But the other thing that's going on there is it's
“走廊里弥漫着煮卷心菜和旧破布垫子的味道”，我们做了一期关于阿加莎·克里斯蒂的节目，我们谈到了阿加莎·克里斯蒂的小说如何为艾德礼政府时代提供了一面镜子。有一种感觉，不是吗，在某种意义上，《1984》是对艾德礼政府的讽刺，就像它是其他任何东西一样。那种紧缩、控制的气氛。这相当……我是不是不公平了？我想是的，是的。我想我最近读了滚石乐队基思·理查兹关于战后伦敦的回忆录。基思·理查兹对坑洼、被毁坏的建筑物、垃圾香烟和所有其他东西的记忆，在《1984》中都有体现。这是对伦敦受损的描述，一个受损的城市。但那里发生的另一件事是它是
London. It's clearly London, but it's not quite London because the clock strikes 13 and Big Brother is there on a poster. And, you know, and it's somewhere called Victory Square. We would never call anywhere Victory Square in our culture. We might call it Trafalgar Square, but Victory Square rings of some other kind of world. So it is London and it isn't London. And I think you started with this quotation, Tom. I think what's interesting that we're ending with 1984 in a way that it is the final hurrah of Orwell's career. It's his last great work, but in its themes, it's also the last great work. All the things he has defended and advanced and actually teased into existence, like our law and our language and our literature,
伦敦。这显然是伦敦，但又不完全是伦敦，因为时钟敲了13下，老大哥就在海报上。而且，你知道，它在某个叫胜利广场的地方。在我们的文化中，我们永远不会把任何地方称为胜利广场。我们可能会称它为特拉法加广场，但胜利广场听起来像是另一个世界。所以它是伦敦，又不是伦敦。我想你以这句引语开始，汤姆。我认为有趣的是，我们以《1984》结束，在某种程度上，它是奥威尔职业生涯的最后欢呼。这是他最后一部伟大的作品，但在主题上，它也是最后一部伟大的作品。他所捍卫、推进并实际上诱导存在的所有事物，比如我们的法律、我们的语言和我们的文学，
in our moral sense, in our trust in each other. He's saying, what happens when all those things go? Rob, you said earlier how much he loved history, how much he loved tradition. I mean, how important that was to him. And of course, you know, Room 101 shows you your deepest horror, your deepest nightmare. And in a sense, it's 1984. I mean, it's his Room 101. He's the idea of, you know,
在我们的道德感中，在我们对彼此的信任中。他在说，当所有这些东西消失时会发生什么？罗伯，你之前说过他有多热爱历史，他有多热爱传统。我的意思是，这对他是多么重要。当然，你知道，101室向你展示了你最深的恐惧，你最深的噩梦。在某种意义上，这就是《1984》。我的意思是，这是他的101室。他是……的想法，你知道，
because Winston Smith is rewriting the times. He's destroying the past. Is that the kind of the emotional core of the novel, do you think? He is facing his worst nightmare with that, the idea that the past can be lost like that. Absolutely. This is a revolutionary government. It's Ingsoc. I don't think for a minute Ingsoc was supposed to be Atlee's government, which he defends with a passion. I mean, he's not really interested in mainstream politics. He's not really interested in institutions. But he fights for Attlee right to the end,
因为温斯顿·史密斯正在重写《泰晤士报》。他正在摧毁过去。你认为那是小说的情感核心吗？他正面对着他最糟糕的噩梦，即过去可以那样丢失的想法。绝对是。这是一个革命政府。它是英格兰社会主义（Ingsoc）。我不认为英格兰社会主义被认为是艾德礼的政府，他对此进行了热情的辩护。我的意思是，他并不真正关心主流政治。他并不真正关心机构。但他为艾德礼战斗到底，
and fair and foul, actually. This is about what revolutions do. Ingsoc is English socialism. It could be English fascism. It doesn't really matter. What happens if all the things history's given us, like say our law and our language, is reduced to nothing? Where are we then? He spent his life trying to listen to the people and the representations of the people. And now he finds a people so misrepresented by their law and their language and their history
实际上，无论好坏。这是关于革命做什么。英格兰社会主义是英国的社会主义。它可能是英国的法西斯主义。这并不重要。如果历史赋予我们的所有东西，比如我们的法律和我们的语言，都被化为乌有，会发生什么？那时我们在哪里？他一生都在试图倾听人民和人民的代表。现在他发现人民被他们的法律、语言和历史歪曲得如此厉害，
that they're extinct. There is no people now. It's a massive warning. But there is that sense in 1984, to go back to the road to Wigan Pier, isn't there, that what I hope there is lies in the proles, that the ordinary people have preserved some, or could preserve some germ of Englishness that the middle classes or the bureaucrats, the people who are in hock to the party that they've lost and the hope resides in kind of the ordinary unsung. You see that in his essay, In the Lion and the Unicorn. You know, this, he has this almost mystical faith. In the Red Wall. Yeah, in the English, exactly, in the Red Wall,
以至于他们已经灭绝了。现在没有人民了。这是一个巨大的警告。但在《1984》中确实有那种感觉，回到《通往威根码头之路》，不是吗，我希望存在的希望在于无产者，即普通民众保留了一些，或者可能保留了一些英国性的萌芽，而中产阶级或官僚，那些向党妥协的人，他们已经失去了，希望在于那种普通的、未被歌颂的人。你在他的散文《狮子与独角兽》中看到了这一点。你知道，他有这种近乎神秘的信仰。在红墙里。是的，在英国人中，确切地说，在英国大众中，不是吗？你认为这在《1984》中也存在吗？是的，他确实有。我的意思是，我认为他是一个民粹主义者，但他也是一个艺术家。他试图做的是通过他的艺术唤起一个值得相信的人民。这并不完全脱离他们的真实状态。只是他的艺术使他们掌握了权力，进入了焦点。他们是大理石中的天使。他有大理石，而艺术使他们成为天使。现在，我们可以永远争论这个问题。但如果我们生活
in the English masses, doesn't he? Do you think that's there in 1984 as well? Yes, he does. I mean, he is a populist, I think, but he's also an artist. And what he tries to do is conjure a people worth believing in through his art. This is not completely removed from how they are. It's just his art brings them into power, into focus. They are the angel in the marble. He has the marble and the art makes them an angel. Now, we could argue about that forever. But if we live
在民主国家，毕竟，我们必须代表某人或某事，这让我想起了英国脱欧辩论，那非常激烈。我的意思是，议会除了代表自己还代表什么？它必须是人民。谁是人民？好吧，你得向我展示。奥威尔的伟大贡献是他向我们展示了他所看到的人民。在《1984》中，他是在说当所有构成人民的东西都被摧毁时会发生什么。你还剩下什么？好吧，你剩下的是一个在酒吧里想要半品脱啤酒的老人，
in a democracy, after all, we have to represent somebody or something, which reminds me of the Brexit debates, which were pretty strong. I mean, what is Parliament representing other than itself? It must be the people. Who are the people? Well, you'll have to show me that. In Orwell's great contribution is he showed us the people as he saw them. And in 1984, he's saying what happens when all the things that make the people have been destroyed. What are you left with? Well, you're left with an old man in a pub who wants half a wallop
和许多根本不知道自己在哪里的人，除了他们不在精英阶层。这就是希望所在。但这不是一个伟大的希望，多米尼克。因为那是我的记忆。这实际上是一个结果证明根本不是希望的希望。最终，你知道，它是……是什么来着，靴子永远踩在脸上，基本上就是你剩下的。你知道，到处都没有希望，这，你知道，说到底确实有点令人沮丧。
and a lot of people who really don't know where they are, except they're not in the elite. And that is where the hope lies. But it's not a great hope, Dominic. Because that's my memory. It's actually a hope that turns out not to be hope at all. And that ultimately, you know, it's what is it, the boot stamping on the forever is basically what you're left with. You know, there is no hope anywhere, which is, you know, a bit of a downer, really, when all is said and done.
好吧，还有一件事。所以显然在这一点上，那是1949年6月出版的，冷战，奥威尔经常被认为在1945年底的《论坛报》中创造了这个短语，冷战正在如火如荼地进行。一直以来，奥威尔对许多英国作家、记者、政治家等来说是一个圣人般的人物。但也有批评者。他的批评者总是抓住的一点是，1949年春天，也就是《1984》出版前夕，奥威尔为他的朋友西莉亚·柯万做了一份名单，
Well, just one other thing. So obviously at this point, so that's published in June 1949, the Cold War, and Orwell is often credited with having coined that phrase in Tribune in the end of 1945, the Cold War is on in earnest. And one of the things that has always, Orwell is a sainted figure to lots of British writers, journalists, politicians, and so on. But there are critics. And one of the things that his critics always seize on is the fact that in the spring of 1949, so just before 1984 was published, Orwell had done this list for his friend Celia Kirwan
在信息研究部，这是由工党政府建立的一个反共部门，不是吗？他有一份38人的名单，像迈克尔·富特、查理·卓别林、E.H.卡尔、J.B.普里斯特利。他说，他们都很可疑。不要让他们做任何工作。你知道，你不能依赖他们。他们基本上都是共产主义者。你认为，我的意思是，罗伯，有些人会说这完全没问题。有些人会说，哦，他是个伪君子，他在做那件事。你知道，他在告发别人，你知道，他是思想警察的一部分。你对此有何看法？
at the Information Research Department, which had been set up by the Labour government as a sort of anti-communist department, hadn't it? He has a list of 38 names, people like Michael Foote, Charlie Chaplin, E.H. Carr, J.B. Priestley. And he says, they're all dodgy. Don't get them to do any work. You know, you can't rely on them. They're all basically communists. And do you think, I mean, Rob, some people would say that's completely fine. And some people would say, oh, well, he's a hypocrite and he's doing the one thing. You know, he's informing on people and, you know, he's part of the thought police. Where do you stand on all that?
首先，他喜欢列名。他总是列出东西。花园里要做38件事。如果德国入侵，22个会投靠纳粹的人。他总是列出他的名单。这是一个老女朋友或想成为女朋友的人，在他病得很重时来看他。我的意思是，他离死不远了。我想她在去世前几个月来了。询问信息。政府不应该信任哪些人来写关于这个国家的文章？我认为这是一个公平的问题。而且我认为奥威尔认为这是一个公平的问题。克服这一点的困难部分在于
The first thing is he loves lists. He's always listing things. 38 things to do in the garden. 22 people who will go over to the Nazis should Germany invade. He's always drawing up his lists. This is an old girlfriend or somebody who wants to be a girlfriend who comes to see him when he's very sick. I mean, he's not far from dying. I think she comes months before he dies. Ask for information. Which people should the government not trust to write well about this country? I think that's a fair question. And I think Orwell thought it was a fair question. The hard part of
在整个战争期间，他深受一个叫詹姆斯·伯纳姆的人的影响，你的听众可能没听说过，但他是在1940年代的一个大人物，他论证了像俄罗斯、美国和欧洲这样的大社会趋向于一种类似的威权主义。但伯纳姆在战后说，这不是关于多个社会趋同，这只是一场直接的斗争。这是民主与共产主义之间的一场直接的、面对面的斗争。你必须决定你站在哪一边。你必须决定。奥威尔绝对被这一点说服了。他评论了伯纳姆，说他是对的。现在是冷战中决定的时刻。然后1947年，杜鲁门引入了行政命令，审查
getting over this is that all through the war, he's hugely influenced by a guy called James Burnham, who your listeners might not have heard of, but he was a massive figure in the 1940s, where he argued about certain big societies like Russia and America and Europe converging into a similar kind of authoritarianism. But Burnham, after the war, said it's not about a number of societies converging, it's just a straight fight. It's a straight stand-up fight between democracy and communism. And you have to decide what side you're on. You have to decide. And Orwell was definitely convinced by that. He reviewed Burnham and he said he was right. Now is the moment in the Cold War to decide. Then in 1947, Truman introduces executive order, which screens
联邦雇员持有什么样的政治观点。当然，这一切都是后来麦卡锡审判的前奏。这份名单确实说明了奥威尔支持伯纳姆的立场，即欺骗、诡计、渗透、同路人、从不坦白你的真实意图的方法，必须被揭露。这就是他在给西莉亚·柯万的38人名单中所做的。它唯一的问题是它不透明。它是秘密的。他的全部观点是，我们必须揭露共产主义者。我们必须展示他们的真面目。我们必须剥去他们真正的效忠对象，但我们必须公开这样做。而他却在悄悄地做。话虽如此，他在疗养院，病得很重，他正试图为捍卫工党政府尽自己的一份力量，
federal employees for what kind of politics they hold. This is all a precursor, of course, to the McCarthy trials that followed later. There is something about this list that tells us that Orwell went with Burnham's position, that such as the methods of duplicity, deceit, infiltration, fellow traveling, never coming clean about your true intentions, that it has to be revealed. And that's what he's doing in his list of 38 people to Celia Kirwan. The only problem with it is that it's not transparent. It's secret. And his whole point was, we've got to reveal the communists. We've got to show them for what they are. We've got to strip away their true allegiances, but we've got to do it in the open. And here he is doing it quietly. Having said that, he's in a sanatorium, he's seriously ill, and he's trying to do his bit in defence of a Labour government,
他热情地支持工党政府。所以你说他病了，他得了肺结核。他去世了，是什么时候，1950年1月，是吗？是的。他去世时，他的声誉正在不断增长。正如我们在节目开头所说，词语“奥威尔式”成为了每个人都理解其含义的词，它成为了一个形容词，在冷战期间以及之后描述了太多东西。为了结束这一集，我们收到了一些问题，询问奥威尔今天会对哪些问题持什么立场。所以伯特·科贝恩的问题，如果奥威尔今天30多岁，你认为他会像在西班牙那样志愿去乌克兰写作和战斗吗？我的意思是，这些显然是非常困难的问题。没有正确或
which he passionately supports. So you said he's ill, he's got tuberculosis. He dies, what, January 1950, is it? Yeah. He dies at a time where his reputation is growing and growing and growing. and as we said at the top of the program the word Orwellian comes to be one that everybody understands what it means it it it becomes an adjective to describe so much during the course of the cold war and indeed afterwards and just just to end this episode we've had a number of questions asking where Orwell might stand on issues today. So the question from Bert Cobain, if Orwell were in his 30s today, do you think he would volunteer for Ukraine to write and fight like he did in Spain? I mean, these are obviously very difficult questions. No right or
错误的答案。但只是，我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题。人们说奥威尔可能会加入自由旅之类的。是的，正如你所知，汤姆，成千上万的人从欧洲去西班牙打仗。我不确定现在是否发生了这种情况。我无法想象他会穿着12码的靴子，作为一个孤独者出现在基辅火车站。我无论如何也看不出这一点。但我认为如果有一场大运动，是的，这是他想参与的那种战斗。实际上，他为《动物庄园》写的一篇序言是直接写给乌克兰的。
wrong answer to these. But just, I mean, it's an interesting question. People have said that Orwell would probably be off with a freedom brigade or something. Yeah. Thousands and thousands of people were going from Europe, as you know, Tom, to fight in Spain. I'm not sure that's happening now. I can't see him turning up as a loner with a size 12 boots on his shoulders in Kiev railway station. I can't for the life of me see that. But I think if there was a big movement, yeah, it's the kind of fight he'd like to be involved in. And actually, one of the prefaces he wrote for Animal Farm was directly addressed to Ukraine.
那是给乌克兰人的。所以他知道乌克兰是一个夹在两个权力集团之间的国家，他关心它。好的。那么赫克托，乔治·奥威尔会对像推特和脸书等当代企业媒体说什么？所以那是另一个，那是，你知道，两分钟仇恨。那是，人们经常引用那个作为社交媒体上发生的事情的例子。你认为这是一个公平的比较吗？嗯，他会对推特和脸书等感到非常紧张，但他们现在玩的是一个非常不同的游戏。他称意识形态家为“留声机”。他们只是重复他们被给予的同样的信息。你现在剪切、粘贴、融合和塑造信息或模因和比喻的方式，这是一个比仅仅成为留声机复杂得多、困难得多的问题。所以他会说出比我能说的更有趣的东西，但不会是沿着留声机的路线。
It was for Ukrainians. So he knew about Ukraine as a country caught between two power blocks, and he cared about it. Okay. So Hector, what would George Orwell say of contemporary corporate media like Twitter and Facebook and others? So that's another, that's, you know, the two-minute hate. That's, people often cite that as an example of what happens on social media. Do you think that's a fair comparison or? Well, he'd be very nervous about Twitter and Facebook and all that, but it's a very different game they're playing now. He called ideologues gramophones. They just repeated the same message that they'd been given. The way you can cut and paste and meld and shape messages now or memes and tropes, it's a vastly more complicated, difficult question than just being a gramophone. So he would have said something more interesting than I'm managing to say, but it wouldn't have been along the gramophone lines.
好的。这是一个致命的问题。亚当·佩恩，如果奥威尔在2022年是一名议员，你会在哪个党派以及那个党派的什么位置找到他？他永远不会成为议员。他从来没有兴趣。我认为这是一个很好的，合理的答案。等一下。这是我知道很多人想要答案的问题，因为他们一直问。罗伯可能会试图回避回答它，但我很想听听他，因为我知道他会有一些，我知道他会想到一些有趣的事情，即使他不会说出来。
Okay. Here is a killer question. Adam Payne, if Orwell were an MP in the year 2022, in which party and where within that party would you find him? He'd never be an MP. He was never remotely interested. I think that's a fine, that's a reasonable answer. Wait a second. Here's the question that I know a lot of people want answered, because they ask it all the time. And Rob may try to wheedle his way out of answering it, but I'm keen to hear what he, because I know he'll have something, I know he'll think something interesting, even if he won't say it.
那就是，奥威尔会站在过去六七年左右英国政治生活的大问题上，这显然是英国脱欧？因为他被双方引用。我很好奇，作为一个写过奥威尔和英国性的人，你认为奥威尔的心，嗯，他的心和头脑会在哪里？嗯，我认为他会支持英国脱欧，因为最终，他相信主权，民主主权。我想他会看一眼欧洲委员会，甚至斯特拉斯堡的欧洲议会，所有人坐在整齐的排里看着电视屏幕。然后他会看一眼下议院，疯狂的议员们跑来跑去挥舞着命令文件，交换座位，互相大喊大叫。我知道他会更喜欢后者而不是前者。
And that is, where would Orwell have stood on the great question of British political life in the last six years or so, which is obviously Brexit? Because he was invoked by both sides. And I'm curious about somebody who's written about Orwell and Englishness, where you think Orwell's heart, well, where would his heart and head have been, would you say? Well, I think he would have been pro-Brexit because in the end, he believed in sovereignty, democratic sovereignty. I think he would have taken one look at the Council of Europe or even the European Parliament in Strasbourg, all sitting in orderly rows looking at TV screens. And then he would have taken one look at the House of Commons, mad MPs running around waving order papers, swapping seats, shouting at each other. And I know he would have preferred the latter to the former.
我认为是前者，那些看着电视屏幕的整齐排座让他感到颤抖。而一个疯狂的下议院，他会享受那种霍加斯式的、传统的威尔克斯式的色彩。英国脱欧，当然。还有一个来自伪狄奥尼修斯的最后一个问题。除了奥威尔，还有其他作家被完全误解他特定观点的人广泛引用吗？嗯，这是一个非常好的问题，但没有人像奥威尔那样被引用得那么多。所以一定是他们有时误解了他，有时又理解了他。
It was the former, I think, the orderly rose watching television screens that gave him the shakes. Whereas a mad commons would he would have enjoyed the Hogarthian, traditional Wilksian overtones of that. Brexit, sure. There's one last question from Pseudo Dionysus, the Areopagite. Is there any other writer apart from Orwell so widely quoted by people who completely misunderstand the particular point he's making? Well, that's a really good question, but there's nobody quoted as much as Orwell. So it must be that sometimes they get him wrong and sometimes they get him right.
我只是很高兴他们在阅读和引用他，愿这种情况持续下去。对于那些想要，从未读过奥威尔的人，如果他们要读一本书，是哪一本？是《动物庄园》还是《1984》？《动物庄园》是一件完美的艺术品。这是朋友赫伯特·里德说的，它完全适合大脑。没有一部分是没有意义的，你知道你的儿子和我的孙子孙女，尽管他们很年轻，他们明白了，他们理解它是关于什么的，这不会是坏事。我记得我，我小时候读完《动物庄园》后被送了一本《1984》，我被它吓坏了，以至于我把它藏在床底下，我偶尔敢
I'm just happy they're reading him and quoting him, long may it last. And to those people who want to, who've never read Orwell, and they're going to read one book, which is the one? Is it Animal Farm or is it 1984? Animal Farm is a perfect work of art. This is friend Herbert Reid said, it fits all around the head. Not one part of it is without meaning and you know your son and my grandsons and granddaughters young as they are they get it they understand what it's about it can't be bad i remember i i um i got given a copy of 1984 after i'd read animal farm as a child and i was so frightened of it that i hid it under the bed and I'd occasionally dare
我很高兴他们还在读他的书、引用他的话，希望这种热度能长久持续下去。对于那些从未读过奥威尔，但想读一本他作品的人，该选哪一本呢？是《动物庄园》还是《1984》？《动物庄园》是一部完美的艺术品。正如赫伯特·里德所说，它浑然一体，每一个部分都意义深远。你知道，你的儿子，还有我的孙子孙女们，尽管他们年纪还小，但他们能领会其中的含义，明白它讲的是什么，这绝对是部好作品。我记得我小时候读完《动物庄园》后，有人送了我一本《1984》，我当时被吓坏了，把它藏在床底下，偶尔才敢拿出来看。
myself to look at it. It took years and years for me to feel brave enough to read it. So he still has that kind of power. Well, he calls it a fairy story, Tom, but actually there's nothing fairy like about it. There are shocking moments. You know, when the dogs slaughter the um the dissidents just slaughter them it it's uh it's there's nothing childish or childlike about it but the funny thing is kids understand it they get it yeah yeah okay well that's been brilliant thanks so much good thank you i've really enjoyed it you guys can be my personal tutors now all right where's the sherry oh yeah where is it it's only a virtual sherry on this show i'm afraid it's boiled cabbage and victory cigarettes for us i'm afraid all right uh so thank you
我自己去看。我花了整整好几年才鼓起勇气读完它。所以他依然拥有那种力量。好吧，汤姆，他称之为童话故事，但实际上它一点也不像童话。里面有一些令人震惊的时刻。你知道，当狗屠杀那些异见者时，简直就是屠杀，这根本不是小孩子气或幼稚的东西，但有趣的是，孩子们能理解，他们懂。好的，太棒了，非常感谢。很好，谢谢，我真的很喜欢。你们现在可以当我的私人导师了。好吧，雪莉酒在哪里？哦，是的，它在哪里？恐怕在这个节目里只有虚拟的雪莉酒，恐怕我们只有煮卷心菜和胜利香烟。好吧，谢谢
for listening to the rest is history and uh we'll see you all next time bye bye bye Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello and welcome to a very short Restless History special that I'm afraid is lacking Dominic, but has me, Tom Holland, and is supplemented by my beloved younger brother, James Holland, presenter of We Have Ways. And, bro, we are joining up, aren't we, to talk about a special offer that you have for our listeners so do you want to just tell them a little bit about it yes so we have got a festival based on the we have ways of making you talk podcast called we have ways fest i mean you can see how we derived it down to that one it's great marketing and it's brilliant it's genius and um i think the wonderful thing about the podcast is that obviously you've got your little club,
感谢收听《历史的余味》，我们下次再见，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》特别短篇，恐怕多米尼克不在，但有我，汤姆·霍兰德，还有我亲爱的弟弟詹姆斯·霍兰德，他是《我们有办法》节目的主持人。兄弟，我们要联手了，对吧？来谈谈你给听众准备的特别优惠，你想给他们介绍一下吗？是的，我们举办了一个基于《我们有办法让你开口》播客的节日，叫“我们有办法节”。我的意思是，你可以看出我们是怎么推导出来的，这营销很棒，简直是天才。而且，我认为这个播客最棒的地方在于，显然你们有自己的小俱乐部，
we've got our independent company, and there's sort of little communities. Crossover, isn't that? Synergy. Synergy and crossover. Synergy and crossover. And what we're trying to do is trying to get your guys to speak to our guys and vice versa. And anyway, we've got this festival coming up,
我们有自己的独立公司，还有一些小社区。交叉，不是吗？协同效应。协同效应和交叉。协同效应和交叉。我们试图做的是让你们的人和我们的人交流，反之亦然。总之，我们即将举办这个节日，
which is a weekend festival. And for those of you who might have been to the Chalk Valley History Festival, which you and I, bro bro are intricately uh involved with it's kind of on the same line so there's lots of talks and chats and discussions and on stages but there's also a little bit of living history and in our case there's also a huge amount of second world war hardware right right because bro let's just explain for those very few listeners of our podcast who may not have listened to yours that we have ways is very much devoted to the
这是一个周末节日。对于那些可能去过粉笔谷历史节的人来说，你和我，兄弟，都参与其中，它和那个差不多，所以有很多讲座、聊天、讨论和舞台活动，但也有一些生活历史展示，在我们的案例中，还有大量的二战装备，对吧？因为兄弟，让我们为那些可能没听过你们播客的少数听众解释一下，《我们有办法》非常专注于
second world war i mean pretty much exclusively devoted to the second world war so if you like the second world war this is for you it really is and if you want to know a little bit more about the biggies such as you know d-day and battle of britain or but also you go into the kind of much more recherche intimate detail would you go so far as to say that there's something for every taste i would go that far yeah i would say this is just a little bit for everybody if you're interested in human drama then our podcast is for you and if you're interested in our podcast then we have ways fest there's even more for you because you can meet your favorite historians not you know and i'm not saying me i'm saying a whole host of people
第二次世界大战，我的意思是几乎完全专注于二战，所以如果你喜欢二战，这就是为你准备的。确实如此，如果你想了解更多关于重大事件，比如诺曼底登陆和不列颠战役，或者更深入、更私密的细节，你会说这能满足各种口味吗？我会这么说，是的，我会说每个人都能找到自己感兴趣的东西。如果你对人类戏剧感兴趣，那么我们的播客适合你；如果你对我们的播客感兴趣，那么“我们有办法节”有更多适合你的内容，因为你可以见到你最喜欢的历史学家，我不是说我，我是说一大群人，
max hastings uh john mcmanus from the states a wonderful catcher hoyer who you know as well bro yes who did our episode on on um yes the second reich yeah the wonderful peter caddick adams who is back from the dead having had a quadruple heart bypass. He's now fine. With his extraordinary jackets. With his extraordinary jackets and cravats. We've got veterans. We've still got veterans. We've got Jack Mann, who was in the SAS and SBS in the desert. We've got the brilliant Phillips Payson O'Brien,
马克斯·黑斯廷斯，来自美国的约翰·麦克马纳斯，还有你也很熟悉的凯特琳·霍耶，兄弟，是的，她做了关于第二帝国的节目，是的，还有出色的彼得·卡迪克·亚当斯，他在经历了四次心脏搭桥手术后死而复生。他现在很好。穿着他那非凡的夹克。穿着他那非凡的夹克和领巾。我们有老兵。我们还有老兵。我们有杰克·曼，他曾在沙漠中服役于特种空勤团和特种舟艇中队。我们有出色的菲利普斯·佩森·奥布莱恩，
Gajendra Singh, Rob Lyman, Jonathan Fennell. We've got some Germans as well, and Austrians. Bernard Kast and Christoph Berg are coming over. Mark Milner from Canada. Some really, really brilliant people. People who are absolutely at the top of their game. People who know far more about the intricate details of various aspects of
加金德拉·辛格、罗布·莱曼、乔纳森·芬内尔。我们还有一些德国人和奥地利人。伯纳德·卡斯特和克里斯托弗·伯格要来。来自加拿大的马克·米尔纳。一些非常非常出色的人。在各自领域处于顶尖水平的人。比我所能希望了解的关于二战各个方面复杂细节了解得更多的人。
Second War than I could ever possibly hope to know. So tell us when this festival is and how people can get tickets. So it's on the weekend of the 22nd to the 24th of July. You can get tickets yes so they can um so it's on the weekend of the 22nd to the 24th of july um you can get tickets on wehavewaysfest.co.uk so that's wehavewaysfest.co.uk um and it's up near silverstone racetrack and um so very easy to get to i've had a um a forward look into the weather forecast it looks absolutely stunning for that weekend um and it's going to be
所以我所能希望了解的。那么告诉我们这个节日是什么时候，人们如何买票。是在7月22日到24日的周末。你们可以买票，是的，所以是在7月22日到24日的周末，你们可以在wehavewaysfest.co.uk买票，也就是wehavewaysfest.co.uk，它在银石赛道附近，所以很容易到达。我提前看了天气预报，那个周末看起来非常棒，而且会
a lot of fun and as you would expect from a any festival in the english countryside in the middle of summer of course there's lots of food there's lots of drink there's lots of other things to see and do um and a lovely convivial party atmosphere katrin himmler katrin himmler's coming as well who is the great niece of oh goodness well yeah and couldn't in sharp contrast her great uncle couldn't have been lovelier so well that sounds unmissable um and uh thank you for listening to this um i hope if you are interested in the second world war that this will be of interest to you um and let's face it who isn't interested in the second world war so bro just one last mention of
非常有趣，正如你对仲夏时节英国乡村任何节日所期望的那样，当然有很多食物、饮料，还有很多其他可以看和做的事情，以及一个可爱、欢乐的派对氛围。凯特琳·希姆莱，凯特琳·希姆莱也要来，她是……天哪，好吧，是的，与她那极其糟糕的叔祖父形成了鲜明对比，她叔祖父可没那么可爱。好吧，那听起来不容错过。谢谢你们收听，如果你们对二战感兴趣，希望这对你们有吸引力。说实话，谁对二战不感兴趣呢？所以兄弟，最后再提一下
of where you can get the tickets and when it is, and then we will say goodbye. Yep, it's the 22nd to the 24th of July, Friday to the Sunday, and you can get tickets on wehavewaysfest.co.uk. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
在哪里可以买到票以及时间，然后我们就说再见。是的，是7月22日到24日，周五到周日，你们可以在wehavewaysfest.co.uk买票。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。